[Music]
okay thank you hello everyone thanks for
coming ok so my name is Michael Janos
i'm one of the co-founder of deep
learning startup craft unity from Krakow
I'm also a PhD student at a g8
University at Krakow so today I'm gonna
talk about image generation with deep
learning techniques and because the
models which generate images are called
generative models the talk is gonna
mainly be about deep generative models
so at the beginning I will introduce
deep generative models in general later
I will say something about two most
popular nowadays classes of models that
is variational auto-encoders and
generative address are net that works
and within each class of model I will
briefly say how can they be used to for
semi-supervised learning tasks and at
the end I'm gonna show a case study with
with some results ok so as I said models
will generate the data I called
generative models so what do we expect
from the generative model if we train
the model on some data set in either
unsupervised or supervised way most
often unsupervised after that we'd like
the model to generate the samples which
closely which closely resembles the
samples from the from the training data
set so if we are working in the domain
of handwritten digits then we'd like to
generate images which look like
handwritten digits not we want neither
random noise we want in their cats or
nor letters so this problem of data
generation is not new and it's often
tackled by modeling probability
distribution over the data space so for
instance if our data are images of 500
by 500 trees
the whole data space is all possible
assignments on 500 by 500 grid so again
if we are working in the domain of
handwritten digits we'd like the model
to assign a ratably high probability to
samples which looks like handwritten
digits and low probability elsewhere so
in the history people came up with some
for some examples like sigmoid belief
networks like the Boltzmann machines or
dbn this last model especially as a
merit of igniting the boom of deep
learning and but nowadays each other has
historical meaning it's not widely used
so let me introduce in let me introduce
more recent examples of models so the
first one is variational out encoders
class okay so variational auto encoder
is the latent variable model what does
it mean the latent variable is a
variable which is unobserved
but influences the value of the data so
for instance in probabilistic machine
learning latent variable models are very
popular for instance mixture of Gaussian
or probabilistic pca is one of the
examples later we have a deterministic
function f which maps the latent
variable to our data space and this
mapping f is used to define the
generative distribution p of x given
that so the F is not encoding our it's
not encoding our image directly but it
is only used to define the probability
distribution x given that okay so
because neural networks are nice to to
model complicated mappings we choose the
F to be a neural network and very often
P comes from some
this is a parametric distributions
family so it can be a multivariate
Gaussian for instance and the output of
F is used to represent the parameters of
of this distribution of this
distribution P so for instance of V if
our P is a Gaussian then F and codes it
means and covariance matrix often
because the dimensionality of X is often
very large in case of images then we
restrict the covariance matrix to be the
diagonal to be the diagonal matrix but
obviously if our data is binary then we
can use Bernoulli distribution okay so
the the process by which we obtain our
our our our data our samples from data
space X is simple at first we sample
that from some prior distribution P of
that it's usually a Gaussian with zero
mean and identity covariance matrix
later we pass this that through the
neural net it encodes our parameters of
the P and later we sample the data from
P how many of you knows about the noisy
encoders models how many of you know
about the de noising how to encode our
models okay
so right now it may be not clear why we
call this why this model has something
to do with how to encode there and so it
will I hope it will become clear when I
say something about learning the
variational ultra encoders because we
have the neural net in our generative
distribution P then we neural networks
with a lot of parameters so we need to
feed these parameters to the data so
here we adopt the maximum likelihood
learning procedure so let's say we our
data our data set X comprises and
samples and our goal
to choose these parameters data of with
parameters that are the parameters of
neural net which maximizes the but
maximizes the log of the probability of
hole observed data set it's this lock of
the probabilities called likelihood so
to visualize this if our if our problem
if our likely who depends on the
parameters in some way then we look for
these parameters which maximizes the
likelihood okay the variational out an
encoder model allows us to compute the P
of X P of our sample so this is just a
marginalization of the joint probability
of X and that but the bad news here is
that does that appears under this
integral in a very complicated way
because we passed that food a neural net
so because neural net is a series of
nonlin nonlinear operation then this
integration is almost often intractable
so we need to choose some different
procedure and we trained the vial by
introducing some function which has
values always lower than our true
likelihood but is close enough to the
true likelihood that when we maximize
this lower bound for parameters theta we
all we also obtain a good solution for
the true likelihood okay so let's
wrestle with math a little bit to derive
the lower bound we introduced some
distribution Q over that and later use
the instance inequality to lower bound
our likelihood so it holds true for
every distribution Q but
the more interesting thing than the
formula for lower bound is rather the
additional term which we need to add to
the lower bound to get our likelihood
because it appears that this additional
term is a distance between the our
distribution queue and posterior
distribution of that given X so it
appears that we are getting closer to
the true likelihood with our lower bound
when distribution Q is close to
distribution to posterior P of Z given X
so hits the visualization of this
phenomenon okay and because we'd like to
have the queue as close to the true P of
Z given X as possible we will formally
introduce the conditionality of Z given
X and we can do the similar trick for Q
like we did for P for generative
distribution so now we can use the
neural net to encode the parameters of Q
so now the neural net and codes from X
observed data space too late and space
and okay so because we have to because
we had to derive the lower bound we now
have both we have not two distributions
involved with the first one is the
generative p and the first and the
second one is the posterior Q so the P
takes that and gives us X and Q takes X
and keeps us as that so now the analogy
with with the noising how to encoders
make may be clear because the noise in
how to encode there is basically a
neural net which has two pieces the
first one takes the input and through
some series of operations give us the
gift so called code and later the second
piece of the of the network takes the
code and
reconstructs our input so the same we
have with our variational autoencoder
but here we are working in the
probabilistic framework so instead of
you know deterministic neural networks
we have neural networks are used to to
model the the probability distributions
again the last argument that a
variational auto encoder is actually an
auto auto encoder this when we decompose
our likelihood which becomes our
training objective which we decompose
into these two terms so the first one is
reconstruction term and the second one
is regularization term reconstruction
term is called because the model both
encoder and decoder has to do a good job
in reconstructing the data because for
given X when we compute the latent code
that later the generative distributions
has to assign a relatively high
probability that X was generated from
that so if you know the denies in how to
encode there's training procedure
let's similar there because actually the
the object if is just the minimization
of reconstruction of the construction
term okay so okay so here is the model
we have some original image X we have
the encoder that is this Q distribution
which gives us the probability over the
latent space and later we have the
generative distribution which encodes
our our latent variable into into our
into our data again okay so when it
comes to semi-supervised learning deep
generative models both variational
auto-encoders
and generative adversarial networks are
very promising approach to
semi-supervised learning so when it
comes to semi-supervised learning with
variational Outland coder
then here our data is a result of the
generative mapping not only from the
latent space set but also from labels so
so here now the neural net takes input
of both types okay and similarly to
training Devine and supervised way here
we also optimize the lower bound for
data point and depending on whether the
point has labeled or not we are either
bounding the Joint Distribution of X and
the label or the date if the point is
unlabeled we lower bound only the the P
of X okay I have no time to derive this
equations further but please consult the
paper all this semi-supervised learning
with the generative models written by d3
Kingma in fact swelling and some other
offers actually the king band max
weddings are the authors of the original
paper out encoding variational bias
which which started which introduced the
variational outturn code their model and
ignited did the research of this of this
class of models okay so next next class
of models generative adversarial
networks although the variational
auto-encoders are quite a hot topic
nowadays there is a lot of research
being done there but guns I figured the
most popular deep learning models now
and they are heavily researched the most
heavily research among the deep learning
models so ok ok the gun framework
introduces two components the first one
is the generator the second one is
discriminator similarly to the
variational outturn code to generate
also
like some latent variable zet and later
transformed it into the into the into
the displayed data space eggs so when it
comes to data generation our generator
is enough we don't need another we don't
need discriminator to generate the data
but the discriminator is used to drain
the gun models so actually the generati
father'll networks are introduces a new
way of training neural networks
introduces new objective and I will
describe what is it about it's okay
generator generates our data and
simultaneously the discriminator tries
to classify whether the example is real
or fake we are training guns on some
data set so so next to the generated
samples we also had the real examples
coming from the coming from our data set
and discriminator tries to tries to say
whether the data which which we put into
it this is real or fake okay so okay so
formally we have our data set X and from
the discriminators perspective we'd like
to discriminator to assign high
probability that the sample coming from
our training set is real and
simultaneously we'd like him to assign
low probability that samples that was
are generated by the generator are fake
are you so when it comes to generator on
the others on on the other side we want
him to generate samples which are so
realistic that they fool the
discriminator so on this generated
samples the discriminator will say that
okay this sample is probably real
although it's fake in real okay so when
it comes to objective
how objective comprises two terms the
first one is responsible for the
discriminator to assign high
probabilities on the real data that they
are real okay and the second term
introduces the conflict between
generator and discriminator because from
the discriminator perspective we'd like
him to assign a low probability that
samples generated by generator are are
real but when it comes to generator he
tries to fool the discriminator so he so
he wants the discriminator to to say
that the samples which which generates
our are real so actually the training
relative address our neural networks
consists of solving so-called min max
gain and the training procedure here is
it's a complicated thing because the
basic procedure consists of alternating
between updating the discriminator
parameters and updating the generator
parameters but honestly every Network
every gun network I used to train the
past was trained with some other
procedure with some modifications to
this to this basic one because the
training of guns suffers a lot of
service of all the problems ok so when
it comes to semi-supervised learning
with gun I'm going to describe the idea
introduced in improved techniques for
training guns papers among the outers
there is young good fellow the alpha of
the original papers for God's so okay so
now the discriminator is used as a
classifier for the data so we extend its
output from 0 mu 0 and 1 to predict all
K classes plus we add the additional K +
1 class which
responsible for predicting that the
sample which is fed to the discriminator
is fake so so when it comes to so now
probability that X is fake
is the responsibility of the last output
of the of the soft marks of
discriminator and probability that X is
real is just the sum over all sort marks
outputs from 1 to K so when it comes to
the objective we decompose it into the
supervised and unsupervised the terms
the supervised is responsible the
discriminator classifies the data
properly while the unsupervised and
supervised takes care that discriminator
classifies the examples from the data
set as real and the second term is that
it wants it's not fooled by the by the
generator so for samples generated by
the weather generator the discriminator
has to predict the k plus 1 class ok so
maybe I will show some results ok so the
first one is image generator
I used celebrity faces data set to Train
both avaya
and gun in an unsupervised way the
celebrity faces data set is a big data
set comprising over 200,000 faces of
famous people and this is there's the
visualization of of some of the examples
just the photo of the face ok
so when it comes to generation the
generation the faces by via so to remind
you the process is simple we have we
sampled the latent variable that
pass it through the neural net and
sample from the generative distribution
px of that so a so let's take a look at
the sample generated by it's something
like this so actually it's undoubtedly a
face but the very the first effect we
can see on these images it's it's kind
of blurriness of the images and this
blurriness is the peculiar feature of
auto-encoders and actually it's it's not
not fully understand understood why it
happens but one of the possible
solutions to mitigate this effect is to
use some extension of the variational
outer encoder for instance deep feature
consistent auto encoder which adds an
additional term into the loss function
maybe the solution okay and our
alternate code there is also able to
reconstruct the data so we passed the
original image to the outer ankle there
we encode it to some code and later the
college with generative distribution P
into the original data space so let's
take a look what are the what are the
results of reconstruction and actually
he's not doing well in reconstructing
faces in some examples the feature of
the face are are saved but a lot of
quite spectacular fails for instance a
don't mask and this face it's probably
not the best free constructor but
probably some parameters of the training
should be adjusted to to improve it okay
so when it comes to generation images of
God so okay it's the
results of divine and here is the
examples by my gun okay so shapes are
definitely sharper than in case of viola
but still they there is some
surrealistic effects added into this
into these faces so they are they are
quite distinguishable from the from the
real examples okay it's the other
example and with guys too when it comes
to semi-supervised learning I perform an
experiment on c4 dataset that is I
splitted the training data set on
labeled and unlabeled data set so I did
it with the split of 1k 2k 4k 8k and 50k
of labeled images and what's more I
trained the later I trained the fully
supervised CNN with the same
architecture as as the gods
discriminator with the same split and
let's check what's the accuracy for C
for data set on on on on test data set
so here is de throughout the result so
when we have very few labeled examples
actually the gun trained in
semi-supervised way outperforms a lot
the this the the supervised CNN and as
we are having more labeled examples this
gap is getting smaller so in the end if
we use all of the all of the labeled
examples for c4 the accuracies
is almost the same okay and here are the
samples generated by bygone trained on
safar it seems that as our label data
set is bigger than these samples are
probably better quality but again when
it comes to technique artists I for
experiments I used the tensorflow
obviously Python and the transfer layer
library built on top
of the tensorflow I also used the cult
which was published by by authors of
various papers okay so that would be
enough thanks for attention if you have
any questions then feel free to ask I
[Applause]
told you that give me very easy
questions first one or two questions so
are there any guidelines what kinds of
architectures work best with guns
I mean you provide you present it on
architecture but you I think
deliberately left out the part whether
you have like CNN inside or put
something else inside and does it matter
a lot yeah yeah I didn't talk about
architectures but for the generator
I used the pretty popular architecture
which involves a series of D
convolutions and in order to improve the
training also the using bar
normalization layer is very it's a very
very needed thing and when it comes to
discriminator on the other hand I used
just a similar architecture too to see
an L switch which classifies the data so
for instance there is a series of
convolutions max puddings and and so on
so so when it comes to architecture
there is nothing special there I mean
you you you presented images as an
example but do these are these methods
also used for like speech synthesis or
music synthesis or something like
yeah obviously these are generative
models here the models would generate
the data so but obviously depending on
the the type of the data we are working
to either text or audio signal we should
obviously use the proper architecture
for that so for instance in NLP
variational outline coders with where we
use the LS TM layer in either decoder or
LST or or encode or encoder device a
very popular choice okay thank you Miho
for your talk and yeah big applause
you